yeah we have the big spectacle we have
the screens we have the thing when we
hit our donation goal there's going to
be the big like fireworks or whatever
for doing the mo that's the moment
so the difference between us and
everybody else is that we also care
about the moments between the moments
[Music]
all right sean do me a favor go to our
document and look at the video that i
posted to the instagram to the instagram
link
so i found this this weekend
i was sitting in the bath
just watch this right before the pond i
watch this yeah
does that okay so i was sitting in the
bath just chilling watching instagram
you ever sit in the bath you're like bad
sundays you just kind of sit for a few
minutes i have kids dude my bath is very
different than yours now well that's
true so i just it was sunday bath just
chilling going through instagram and i
got this video
of this lady
uh it's a woman from germany i think
she's german and uh a guy and they're
running together on a 200-meter race at
the paralympics she's blind and he's the
guide runner and they win the race and
they start hugging and she's all crying
is that the coolest video you've seen
today or what this i didn't actually
understand what was happening it just
looks like they're racing against each
other uh i wouldn't have even known what
this was if you hadn't said anything
so
she's blind and she's must not be fully
blind and what they do in the
paralympics is she's like if you're if
you're not
yeah they put a blindfold on everyone
because some people might be legally
blind and they could still kinda see a
little bit and so what they do is they
put this blindfold on everyone and then
these women are are like really fast
women so like another woman can't be
their guide because they're just you
know faster men who could keep up and so
it's they're all teamed up with a guy
who
helps their foot into the blocks and
puts their hand in the right place and
then has to run alongside them stride
for stride and they'll say like all
right you're in second now or like
you're in first like all right we're on
the straightaway like pretty cool stuff
and it seems really rewarding i'm gonna
do this so i've contacted
um
a track coach you saw this video
you got emotional you know the bath bomb
started hitting and uh i started getting
misty and you just decided
this is what i'm born to do i'm gonna be
a guide runner or you want somebody to
guide you which one are you trying to do
so
uh so here's the deal i am now i'm still
fast enough that i am as fast as some of
these blind women i'm not as fast as the
blind men but i can keep up with the
women a little bit and i probably have
five more years where i can keep up with
them and so i can't i'm not good enough
to go to the olympics i never was and
particularly now as i get older i'm not
good enough this is my shot this is my
way to get into the olympics is to
be a guide runner for the for a blind
lady
this
somebody called you out on twitter for
this they go
he did it the perfect sam backhanded
compliment
because you were like backhand
comfortable like myself yeah you kind of
yourself i don't know the whole sport
because you were like
i'm not as fast as i used to be and i'm
still fast enough with this to keep up
with an elite blind woman
that wasn't my point i'm just saying
like it's just a fact they're like this
lady she read 23 seconds i can run 23
right now
i'm not there's no
this is like awesome i think it's
awesome i think it'd be way more fun i'm
not like making fun of these people you
have to be a good person to do this at
the paralympics you're not a good enough
person dude we were too rough around the
edges
yeah you're going to get canceled before
the race you're going to say i tip like
50 when i go out to eat i'm a great guy
yeah that's what you got to ask yourself
where's that coming from what what are
you trying to cover up with these 50
tips i'm a good dude man i'm glad you
could do this i'm glad you brought up
the olympics so
um
probably don't even know this the winter
olympics are going on right now half the
people learned that like yesterday
they're going on right now the ratings
are like the lowest it's ever been
all right and then i forgot to tell you
this but this is the most important
thing uh i can't believe we didn't talk
about this earlier to be honest with you
because if you're listening to this and
you like what you're hearing right now
and you haven't gone and subscribed to
the my first million podcast wherever
you get your podcast
then that's the thing you've got to do
there's nothing more important than
doing that right now and don't do it
because i said to do it
do it because you want to do it do it
because that's who you are
[Music]
uh winter olympics in general are like
you know
less popular than the normal olympics um
some people are super into it my buddy
trevor uh he's my roommate he
loves the olympics like the olympics
would come around he's like clear the
schedule 24 7. i'm just watching
whatever's on and like i kind of got
into it with him i do that too by the
way before the summer
no no no no summer winters are real
exactly exactly so um
you should say that when you're in the
winter olympics uh guide bobsled team
just be like i can't wait to do this for
a real sport um so
so
i was so i i was watching the super bowl
then like after the super bowl just like
immediately auto cut
to the winter olympics and um and i was
watching somebody do like the toboggan
and i just thought of a very
controversial take this take was too
spicy for twitter i didn't even dare put
it on twitter because i was like i'm
gonna get so much heat for this the
toboggan is the person who lays on the
sled i thought that was the luge
okay maybe i maybe it was a bobsled
maybe it was a luge maybe it's a
different way was it like one person
it was one person they were running
different pushing that
yeah the difference is is that one they
go face first and one they go like on
their bet on their back on their butt
legs first
so
completely irrelevant to what i'm saying
the yes one of those was happening and
then
i thought
so our buddy nick tweeted this out
during the super bowl because nick likes
to just like stare the pot on twitter
that's like his character on twitter and
he was like
watching sports are a complete waste of
time you know what i'm doing right now
i'm working on my business that's how
you get ahead when everybody's zigging
you zag he's doing something
earlier that day he was texting us
photos of him partying so yeah dude he's
parties all the time like this guy's not
like
nick lim's like the most charmed life
he's like oh
you know i'm tired of playing golf so
i'm going to now relax
right like guy's got like i guess self
storage is a pretty hands-off business
so you know he's got a lot of time on
his hands but he likes to tweet stuff
that's pop and uh so people started you
know fighting about it here's my take
that's kind of like that
that i just didn't want to get into it
on twitter
the olympics are an example
of
how to waste your life
so
here's
here's the spicy take
so i i'll explain i i understand that's
harsh but uh but here's here's the take
i once was uh listening to an interview
with this guy max levchin max leviton
created paypal
which is a pretty important like
internet invention ability to send money
to each other on the internet
so he creates paypal paypal becomes a
huge success
and for his next act do you remember the
company that he started next
it was called slide i think slide and uh
describe what slide did for the people
it was advertising technology or games i
forget but it didn't know it was like
well many many little mini apps on top
of myspace and facebook so it'd be like
that's right
yeah like you want to put up a slideshow
of like photos with some music on it you
slide you want to throw sheep at your
friend you slide slide makes all these
apps that are like you know poke your
friend oh we created an app called
double poke it's better than that they
made money through ads i think it was so
it was ultimately almost like it was
just like a way to get lots of
impressions and then
ultimately the whole thing lost money
didn't make any money they ended up
selling to google mostly because of max
i think i think it was google that
bought them um so they whatever it
didn't it ended up working but the point
was they go max you did paypal then you
had slide which which had like explosive
growth on top of these really fast
growing social networks but ultimately
kind of fills it out you know like what
have you learned
he said one thing that like has stuck
with me
it stuck with me which means i must have
been guilty of it many times for this to
stick with me this this hard he goes
well here's what i learned with slide
you can spend be careful because you
could spend your whole life
optimizing for nothing and um and he's
like you could optimize anything
to the to the infinity degree he's like
so we come out with super poke or
whatever their apps were at the time
like you know super poke it's like
better than a poke
and then all of a sudden i have these
brilliant engineers from stanford and
whoever else and their job every day was
to increase the poke per user ratio by
this much to get clicks up to get you
know to earn an extra three cents per
click
and ultimately we spent years just
optimizing the viral coefficient of how
i can get super potential right across
my space it's like and his message was
be careful because it doesn't matter how
smart you are anything can be optimized
to like infinity so pick wisely like you
know the the same brain power and energy
went into building paypal that went into
building these silly apps on slide
and i've been like you know that's been
my thing my my sort of mountain to die
on which is like project your question
is everything
but you are so wrong but this is the
olympics this is the olympics this
person who's who's running and then
diving into this toboggan
they basically to me they got tricked by
society society basically told them hey
you know what devote your whole life
give up everything basically to train
every day to become the best in the
world at this arbitrary thing that we've
made fun of you're not are you gonna
make a lot of money from it no
are you going to uh you know develop
these like you know amazing other
aspects of your personality in your life
no you're gonna go super single-minded
to turn yourself into a human weapon of
doing this one random thing sliding your
body in a tube down this chute for 40
seconds and your job is to get it from
40 seconds to you know to
39.98 seconds that is your life and then
hey when it's over uh good luck just go
figure out the rest of life now that
you're you've peaked at age 26 and then
you know go go ahead and figure the rest
of life out so i think the olympics are
an example of optimizing your life on
the dumbest [__] okay go all right i'm
going to make an argument to say why you
are entirely incorrect and i've got
wonderful examples these correct
oh i thought you were going to tell me
yeah
here's why sports represents so much
more there's only basically two things
that transcend language religion and
culture it's basically art and sports i
think those are the only two things
maybe family but that's about it and so
what sports represents is so much more
than just optimizing the the seconds not
only is it about like the um
being disciplined and all that and how
those are good qualities but it's it's
about culture so think about this in the
19th uh i think it was 33 olympics or 32
olympics in berlin it was in it was in
uh berlin and and hitler was in the
stands doing a zeke hell and they were
still getting there at that point they
just started like you know messing
around with the jews and getting rid of
them jesse owens wins the long jump in
100 meter dash when hitler's saying like
well the aryan race is the best race and
anything
you know outside of that is inferior and
jesse owens sticks it to him another
example is this woman named kathryn
switzer you probably don't know who she
is but have you ever seen this famous
picture of this woman running a marathon
and there's a priest pushing her out of
the road
so
okay so her name is catherine switzer
look it up so look up uh marathon woman
push and you'll see this famous picture
so for a long time women were not
allowed to run marathons so there was no
such thing as first of all women weren't
even in uh the olympics and they thought
that like oh women are just too weak to
run and this woman came along and uh i
don't remember what year it was i think
it was the 70s and she starts running
this marathon and there's this famous
picture of this guy pushing around the
street and that like signals to all
women like no f this you could do it all
right you got this and then you got guys
like this guy who you can't see all the
way his name's steve prefontaine steve
prefontaine he ran in the 1980s
uh
1972 olympics i believe in
munich uh munich and what happened at
that olympics was basically
a bunch of terrorists took over and they
killed a bunch of israeli athletes have
you heard about this they took over this
helicopter they kidnapped these israeli
athletes these wrestlers they threw them
in the helicopter the israeli army tried
to like capture them and it blew up in
it and it ruined the whole olympics and
you know what they said the next day
they go
f this we gotta go compete we this is
what we have to do we gotta compete we
gotta bring this together and see
pre-fontaine this guy who's on my wall
he was at the olympics and he said these
amazing quotes like to give anything
less than your best is to sacrifice the
gift he eventually inspired this guy
phil knight and bill bowerman to go
start a company that they called nike
and steve prefontaine was their first
athlete and this is all because of the
olympics and this is all because of
sport and the olympics happens just
every four years that is one way to like
bring a beginning and an end to the last
trailing four years of training and
preparing a discipline and it
accumulates in this thing this is
incredibly essential it represents race
relations women's rights [__] go look at
the um every year at the olympics they
do the the procession where your country
comes in they've got this thing called
um i forget what they call it but it's
for people who are going through war and
who don't have a country so for example
i believe in
london i think it was like sudan or or
the congo republic i forget one of those
countries was not considered a country
by like they're going through civil war
and so they just said hey we're just
going to create a refugee country you
now have your own country or when taiwan
and hong kong are going through their
issues it's a huge deal that for the
olympics that they announced well are
they going to have their own country or
are they not or uh recently a kenyan
swimmer was in the first ever summer
olympic swimming this is beyond sports
this is a really big deal that's my plea
that's why i think this is actually
awesome
tell me how you really feel
that was good right that was good um
just tell me one thing who's the who's
the who's the greatest um
luge uh competitor of all time you just
name them
um everything that i just said was only
for these summer olympics the winter
olympics are fake
if you need a judge on your sport it's
probably not that real of a sport
that's why track and field
swimming and all those like races that's
why they're like real sports
yeah so everything i said no no that
it's only every four years i'm mostly
just messing around also i like i like
watching the olympics in general i think
it's cool obviously i think it's cool if
people like excel and things
that's awesome
my point is
i think that there's like uh you know
like for example if my kid
was like had the potential if you told
me right now hey your kid has the
potential
to be the greatest
you know like at uh whatever um the
greatest
third person in the bobsled
in uh in the country but here's what you
have to do every day every weekend for
the you know the the next 20 years of
their life
is going to go into optimizing their
body and mind to be able to do this
which essentially is what goes into like
becoming an olympian right you're trying
to become the best in the world
at an arbitrary game that was made up
and
you have to sacrifice a huge amount of
your life and focus and attention and
energy and talents
you decide to invest into this
and the thing you get out is
character building life lessons um
and the other thing you get from the boy
scouts you know potentially a moment of
fame
when
if you want if you actually did achieve
the thing and you have the you know sort
of the
the the knowing inside your heart that
that this was this was good so like you
know would i rather be sp you know steve
prefontaine
this you know this good looking mustache
runner guy or would i rather have been
phil knight i'd rather be phil knight i
think actually he's the perfect example
what did preventane get out of
you know nike nothing and so he actually
uh where's he now right he died three
years into finding the company from a
drinking driving accident so yeah you're
right
okay
joke's not so funny now it didn't work
out
wait so he was actually a co-founder of
nike or he just inspired them um he he
he was he was in their crew and he was
their first sponsored athlete and like
their fifth or tenth employee or
something like that and um if you ask
phil knight who you know what who's
nike's mentor or sorry who's nike's
mascot they'll say it's prefontaine
yeah so anyways my point is i think that
there's a lot of things that are fun and
they're best done as hobbies versus
trying to become the best in the world
at it right uh i could play you know
call of duty and have a bunch of fun
with my friends
um i can even play you know the
competitive side of things just because
i like to scratch that itch and i play a
couple hours a week but once i try to
become the best in the world at it
the level of sort of sacrifice and over
indexing on that thing and hey you could
do it you could over index on anything
you could try to become the fastest
typer in the world you could try to
become the best photographer of brown
leafs in the world and you know like you
could do all those things
so choose carefully choose which one you
want what you really want to go into
it's like people who dedicate their
lives to be an average d3 basketball
player it's like
it could work you could you could you
could go to the nba but like odds are
the papers or the writings on the on the
wall like it's probably not going to
happen so maybe you should actually like
study a real major instead of basket
weaving or communications right and if
you enjoy it fantastic if you're
enjoying every step of the way fantastic
but a lot of things in my experience are
most enjoyable when done as hobbies
versus when done with the competitive
pursuit of becoming the absolute best in
the world at it uh are
the guy used to work out of his his dojo
he used to tell me that i was like oh
yeah i really like this so i might start
a business around it he goes
oh yeah
dave grossbot he goes
easiest way to [__] up a hobby is turn
it into a job
and i remember just hearing that being
like
that's interesting i actually never
really thought about that yeah actually
there are some things that are really
fun as hobbies that become really unfun
as jobs right it's like working at a
cinnabon right it's like oh yeah i love
eating cinnabon
working at a cinnabon smelling cinnabon
eating free cinnabon anytime you want
now it's not so funny that's how i feel
about business sometimes like whenever i
i go to my friend nick ray always hosts
these meet up these meetups and i'm miss
frowned so i go and he's like say your
name and what you do for work and i'm
like i don't want to say what i do i'm
sick of talking about work that's all i
ever talk about is business like i don't
want to talk about that [__] ever again
right so i i feel ya all right let's do
some other stuff um
[Music]
okay i don't know where we want to go we
can go ideas or we can just shoot shots
that's all we have i think well i have a
couple things i didn't actually put them
on this list yet but uh okay so i'll
give you a quick idea um i was in a
pitch meeting so this founder was
pitching me his company
and uh he was just like screen sharing
so he's showing me a product demo
and it was like a it's like a data
analytics uh tool and he was like yeah
so like check this out if i go to excel
and then he like
he just opens up the browser i've never
seen this before he goes he just opened
up the browser he goes sheets dot new hi
enter and then it opened up a google
sheet like a blank spreadsheet
and i go i go whoa what's just what was
that and he goes oh yeah he goes i'll
show you later because he was because i
was he was so annoyed with me just going
on tangents about every random thing he
was doing like he wanted to show me his
product
not the fact that you could type
sheets.new and save myself like
i [__] google i google google drive
then i get to drive then i click new
then i go down the menu then i find
spreadsheet then i click new spreadsheet
then i get to a sheet it's like this
like annoying thing i do six times a day
and um and so just seeing this was like
well that's awesome and it reminded me
that there's a whole company out there
called go links have you ever heard of
go links
no what is that so so i saw this in a um
or when i was working at twitch
the kind of like whoever the i don't
even know it was job title like vp of
everything that kind of that number two
guy at twitch
um my boss this guy dan he was like he's
like god we have so many documents in
this company
and now i just have bookmarks and tabs
just with like all these docs open at
all times in this company he's like and
if i ever want to look up like oh the
annual plan
it takes me like five minutes every time
i want to find it because i don't know
why we don't just use go links and what
go links does is it lets you set up a
thing that's like
go dot
annual plan or like you know you could
just basically type in like a human
readable
link and you could anchor it to any doc
and so let's say you know you that's
anchored to the 2021 doc oh now it's
2022. cool we just swapped the link out
we just already said we like we can
still always type go slash
you know uh annual plan or go slash plan
and go slash pan will now take us to the
2022 doc and i saw this i was like wow
this is actually so useful to just be
able to quickly find and like revoke
access properly to to different
documents
and so um so i really like this most
people haven't heard of this and i think
it's a very expensive tool i think it's
like a pretty like enterprising tool i
see at the top here they raised a
27 million 27 million series a okay so
doing pretty well obviously so i think
somebody could build this is like a very
simple product i think somebody could
build a go links for like the startup
level world more i got you bro indie
hackers
i just invested in one oh really what is
it yes so i told you about it too i
swear
i i told you about it uh it's called
nera and
i'm in this too i mean this too oh i i
so that's the same thing right so this
is this is slightly different i don't
think they do the the shortcuts to the
links maybe this is a feature they
should add what they are doing what mira
is doing is
we all companies have all these docs and
then people get fired or they move teams
or whatever but people still have access
it's like oh yeah i still got this link
it just opens up the like the numbers
for the for the company or like yeah
this contractor we hired still has
access to all of our files but like
who the heck can go audit and keep up
and scrub
the access for this thing that's like
it's like a very big problem like your
company's most sensitive data is all in
the cloud
and then the cloud like access is shared
amongst like so many people and there's
no central place to see
who sees what and so nira's building
that they're building the who has access
to what yeah but i think the link thing
is a feature maybe yeah maybe it is a
feature
i'm saying i think it's a
feature that can be standalone because
adopting something like nero is like
something that's going to go through my
like you know chief security officer
type of thing like this is going to go
through our cio or cso
whereas this go links thing is something
that like you know me and my
one person who i work with like we're
both just irritated with these super
long ugly google docs links that like
um
you know like we can't find anything it
takes forever to find stuff they they
they have a free plan
near it does
no go links oh go leagues does yeah yes
i think yeah i don't know at one point
they they do this but
i don't know why this is not more
popular this is like like a real problem
and then this also just got me thinking
like
what else is like this what are the
other problems that are like these like
i call them paper cut companies
so um
you know death by a thousand paper cuts
so like what's a thing that's irritating
but you do it so often that it's just a
constant paper cut that just annoys you
screenshots is another one that like
sharing screenshots was one that was a
big paper cut uh i invested in this
company called bubbles that tries to
make that better loom makes it work
better i remember bubbles is it working
uh i don't know i've caught up with them
in a little while i know it was working
initially they raised much money uh from
that but i feel like it hasn't taken
over like you know the loom market yet
but maybe it's going into a different
market i'm not dude the screen the
screenshot one's a good idea also the
copy and paste
the copy and paste i've been thinking
for years how can i optimize a copy
better clipboard
yes a better clipboard i've been
thinking about that for a long time um
it's been that's always an interesting
thing to me is is is the clipboard
that's really interesting but the the
problem with these types of products
is you have to truly be inventive i
don't particularly have that muscle to
like be that creative so people who
invent things like this or like even
like um
what's that guy named howie who's got
the huge company uh air table air table
uh
creating something like air table which
is basically kind of like excel but
different and better or even creating
like a notion
i don't like these people kind of are
geniuses
who can like come up with like these
weird product features and like they
just know that like if you hover your
mouse over this it needs like that
they're so complicated they're so
complicated it's pretty amazing yeah
they um they're big on details and i'll
tell you the the best thing i heard
about details like this i'm i'm not
detail-oriented like if if this camera
showed my desk you would see like yeah
i'm obviously not organized or
detail-oriented like everything is
sloppy even my camera right now is
actually slightly crooked but i just
don't care i just don't care about
details and pretty much anything i do so
that's why you're talking like your neck
a little bit yeah that's why i often do
this
i end every podcast with a crick um
but you know like i'm not a sweat the
details person but i remember the first
time i used slack i used slack really
early on it was like in beta i should
have invested in it i just wasn't an
investor back then i didn't think about
it that way
but i used it and i remember the first
thing one thing i did was i
was telling our designer hey uh yeah
here's the color for like our logo or
whatever uh or they sent it to me and
they just sent the hex code so like you
know
heck you know like pound
cff or you know 373 and it just create
it turned it into a small tiny color
swatch
and i remember thinking
why the [__] did they do that like
what level of care went into
caring that the hex code would just auto
format with a little swatch next to it
that's what i mean nobody would do that
unless you were like a real product
designer who sweat the details who used
this product all the time and just
dedicated yourself to like any time you
could just scratch your own itch and
irritate you know like remove one paper
cut from your own user experience you're
going to do it and so this is why also
working on your own products working on
products that you want to be the user of
helps because you'll get so annoyed at
the paper cuts you'll just get rid of
them yourself all right let me give you
an example of another one so i'm only
bringing this up because of colors so
i've told you about this company called
wgsn they make 90 million dollars a year
and they tell it's a it's like an info
product all about colors i don't want to
talk about that but so ben go to so it's
called coolers dot co c o o l like cool
o r s dot co coolers dot co so basically
whenever i'm creating a new product or a
new website you have to pick like a good
color scheme and like separate this is
badass dude it's so good so basically
let's say that like for me mostly i'm
just like a black and white guy i want
the text to be black i want the
background to be white but then you
still need like some radiant of gray and
then you want the links to be some like
gradient of red what goes good with that
what goes good with this color of blue
and so what you could do is look at the
very bottom where it says um when you
see the lock button when you see so
basically it shows you five colors you
can randomly select one or you can tell
it which one you want and let's say you
like the blue you click lock on that and
then it shows you four more that fit
that then you click lock on the next one
and it shows you three more that fit
that is this golden is this website
amazing or what that's amazing that is
so good
and i love it when i i've been going
this for years and years and years
at first it started out just like this
tiny little project now it gets like
five million monthly uniques according
to similar web and it's got a pro
version it's got all these amazing
versions so look yeah it gets five
million monthly uh monthly uniques it's
got a figma plugin a chrome extension
it's got all this amazing stuff and they
have a pro version that i actually don't
know what you get with the pro version
but how neat is this this is a paper cut
problem that actually i bet has turned
into a business that makes many many
many millions of dollars a year and this
is the type of company that you could
own for like 30 years and it probably
would make pretty consistent seven
figure profit every single year
yeah how does this one make money does
it uh charge renee so they do a couple
things if you look on the top you'll
notice that they have a squarespace ad
so they have it has ads and then they
they have a pro version so it's only
it's built 36
a year which is stupid and you get uh
lots of different um features
um
but i would charge like way more because
you already know this company has like
a basically what you would do is if i
own this
i log on
i look at all the email addresses i've
ever collect i do like a control find
uber
adobe whatever like companies that have
bought it
and i go and upsell them on some like
crazy high thing right
can i tell you um the philosophy again
i'm not detail-oriented but here's a
philosophy i heard that i was like oh
this explains
why some things when i was on some
products some experiences some hotels
when i go into them
i'm like this just feels good what's
going on here i can't even put my finger
on what feels good about it
i was talking to scott harrison he's the
founder of charity water and charity
water puts on dope events everything
they do is dope so like
i think when he was starting it he heard
some quote that was like
um isn't it sad that charity is marketed
with less um
less like um
less design and style
than
um you know the the 73rd
brand of toothpaste it's like yeah it's
like true it's like you know like a
crest or like you know whatever right
aqua whatever it's called aquafresh you
know like the
they put more design and marketing and
energy into like how that looks and
feels and the colors and the the
typeface and all that than a charity
that's saving children would put into
their brand so he decided early on all
right i'm going to build an epic charity
brand because i think it's going to
matter i think people are going to
donate more if we come across if we do
better marketing like we can't just like
say that that's only for rich companies
and we're this poor nonprofit that
always has to look crappy and so he does
he he's a photographer he takes photos
they put on epic events so at their
events if you ever go to one of their
events it just flows it's just nice like
every
everything's just club promoter right
he was a former club promoter so he gets
it and he goes my he i go i go dude what
what is it about your events i was like
because you have the big spectacle like
at any event like every time he doesn't
mma trust up it from the year before so
there's always like this like spectacle
where it's like there's 10 000 screens
and on every screen there's one person
from one village that we are gonna fund
tonight it's like okay that's the
spectacle and that's always cool but i
was like dude it's the other stuff that
like i don't know why it just feels
different what is it he goes my wife
victoria she's the brains behind this
she has a phrase for this she goes
um all the magic
is in the moments between the moments
i know what she goes it's the moments
between the moments and i was like
what's that mean he goes
yeah we have the big spectacle we have
the screens we have the thing when we
hit our donation goal there's going to
be the big like fireworks or whatever
for doing the mo that's the moment so
the difference between us and everybody
else is that we also care about the
moments between the moments what's it
gonna be like in between those moments
everybody else only puts their energy to
those we focus on the moments between
the moments and i just started i was
like i still don't really understand how
to use this but it became this like kind
of mantra so anytime i really want to
pull something off like today's
valentine's day i'm trying to pull
something off
it's like uh what are the moments
between the moments that i could just
level up here because that's where to
the other person they're like oh you
didn't have to do that like this took
extra care to like to think about
you know the walkway between the two
rooms and not just what's in the two
rooms
now that i'm a hotelier i'm reading the
biography of the guy who started the
four seasons
and he talks about he started in the 60s
and he was like before then like people
didn't necessarily have like the
fanciest mattresses so we went and just
got the best mattresses that money could
buy or like you couldn't get your um
shoes cleaned at a hotel and so we just
hired a guy to clean shoes or
the showers weren't necessarily good so
our showers were just almost as good as
every other shower but we just got the
best shower heads
and he was like oh we just focused on
all these really tiny things and it
added up and made it amazing right
do you uh have you read this the main
guy for hospitality there's like the
shake shack guy i think he's written one
danny meyer his book's called setting
the table yeah i read it it's awesome
and then there's uh that guy chip you
know this guy chip have you heard of
this guy chip uh conley yeah he had a
hotel business is it called hotel zephyr
i think no so it's a boutique
i think that's one of his hotel that's
like the specific hotel his group is
called something else
uh he has a couple like a bunch of
boutique hotels that i guess chip conley
yeah
yeah he worked at airbnb for a long time
right that's right i think he was like
the advisor key advisor special advisor
to like the founders of airbnb
so in um
in masters of scale did you ever listen
to the master skill episode about airbnb
about the five-star experience thing
oh yeah go ahead tell it so so you
should do this for your airbnb so i i do
this for i use for all my startups i'll
do this at one point in time for
everybody it's an amazing framework so
founder of airbnb brian chesky goes on
and they were talking about like okay
what makes air what made airbnb special
he goes okay we do this exercise i think
he calls it the 12 star experience so he
goes all right um
he sat down with the team he goes okay
uh a guest is going to stay at an airbnb
right that's our product our product is
actually not the website where you book
the thing it's the experience you have
when you go to the place we all agree on
that everyone's like yeah we all agree
on that okay cool so
uh what's a one star experience with
airbnb it's like oh i i booked the place
and my card gets charged twice for no
reason now i gotta go contact support
and then i never get a message from the
guy so i'm uncertain when i get there
about how i'm gonna get in um and then i
get there and it looks nothing like the
photos and there's cockroaches
everywhere and the bed is you know the
sheets are dirty whatever that's a one
star experience okay cool
what's a three star experience so they
they define a three-star experience it's
like all those little moments but
they're a little bit better
and he's like all right what's a
five-star experience and this is where
the team the first time they do this
exercise seems like all right five star
experience is like you know
super easy to book on the website um you
get there and the keys are in the lock
box and just opens up and uh
you know it looks just like the photos
and you're feeling good and the the host
leaves you kind of like a bottle of wine
on the table or like you know some some
mint chocolate on your pillow let's put
it that way
he's like okay great that's a five-star
experience everyone's like yeah that's
five stars they're ready to like leave
the meeting great we need to find it
here goes cool what's a six star
experience and they're like oh [__]
foreign what do you want us to say
they're like okay instead of a mint you
know chocolate on your pillow there's a
bottle of wine they say all right what's
a seven star experience and they're like
all right seven star experience you know
they pick me up from the airport there's
they're standing there with a name on my
name on the sign and they i don't have
to go figure out the uber in the city
they drive me home and then they you
know on the way out they hand me you
know a little cheat sheet of cool stuff
in the neighborhood that i can go check
out
he like keeps pushing the envelope he's
like what's a 12 star experience and he
forces them to think through what the
most magical
experience could be using their product
and he's like okay cool now we know
what's possible now we know in the
extreme scenario like we took the
ceiling from here we blew the roof off
and now we can go here right we took the
knob we turned it to 10 and then we said
no we want the volume to go higher and
now we can take the volume up to 15. and
sure we're not going to be able to
deliver that every time but if we hadn't
even thought about it like we couldn't
ever dream of translating any element of
that into our into our experience
and at the company there was a time
pre-covered when when they didn't have
you know what the
when covet happened like things change
and like we got to survive just like
most businesses but prior to that for a
long time brian had been tinkering
with building an airline
and the reason being is the 12 star
experience is basically well like what
if we flew you there and you know the
moment you booked we picked you up and
you were on our flight and
you know a perfect 12 star would be like
it's your own plane this and that yeah
and they were even tinkering with either
opening an airline or offering flights
right and that and that's an example
that that that example didn't come to
fruition because a bunch of stuff but
that's an example of like man that
actually could have been reality from
that exercise but other things did so
for example the airbnb uh what was
called experiences or whatever
where okay you get to the city now what
well my stay is not just the house i'm
in it's what i do outside of the house
well cool wouldn't it be awesome if we
could take you on a wine tasting thing
that could just be part of
what was already booked for you it just
turned out to be amazing it's like a
local person guiding you through this
thing not just this uh corporate you
know um you know tour bus
but like somebody who really actually
like works at the winery who just does
this in their spare time wouldn't that
be an amazing experience and that
actually became a part of the product
and uh you know what if the photos
weren't so crummy right so like all
these things they they they like put
effort into doing them to me that's how
you translate the moments between the
moments thing into real life so whenever
i do this with our companies it's like
cool so
what would be a great experience oh you
get the product and it works
okay what's a what's a six star
experience
well the packaging
actually are practically kind of weird
it's like hard to open it'd be awesome
if this just was easy to open i didn't
have to go get the scissors and fumble
with this
oh yeah okay
what else
would be cool if it inside every package
they also was this other little thing
that would be awesome right and then
like what if the founder followed up
with like you know like hey how was it
two days later and they you know they
actually cared what i thought okay what
what else and so
this like this exercise of take your
team through one star three star five
star seven star our nice 12 star
experience
is like it works in any business not
just hospitality
to him yeah i i remember hearing this
story years ago i think this he did this
in like 2014 or 15 and it's always stuck
with me
yeah um okay let me tell you about a
company that i think
i think i could i could start one of
these and i think i could i could knock
it out the park so there's this company
that
i've always talked about
well actually no i'm gonna tell you
about that in a second i want to tell
you about one other thing there's this
guy named sam evans do you know sam
evans
sam evans uh is that the uh very like
slick-backed hair guy
yeah what's his thing consulting.com so
he talks all right so this guy named sam
evans he rubbed me the wrong way for a
long time and looking back i think i was
actually wrong and he seemed like an art
guy so he had this website called
consulting.com which if i had to put it
at its worst it was basically a course
that was like two thousand to ten
thousand dollars that taught you how to
start a business
at best
it's like it like it's an accelerator
and the reality is it just like is a way
to like it's like a community and a
course on starting a company
and he scaled it to like 30 million in
revenue
and
it was just him and he hired all these
people and built this office in new york
and he was posted on social that they're
doing 50 or 60 million in revenue and
then he vanished and he had a youtube
video come out today that says and he
and he just says i'm back he's like for
the past two years i hated life we
scaled too quickly and so we were
spending like 50k a day on facebook ads
and we weren't even making that much
profit so i decided to change everything
and over the last two years we've
crushed it he goes for example in
january
uh this course he goes we got rid of
like there was three courses now we only
sell two or one and last month in
january we made eight hundred thousand
dollars in revenue and our expenses
which includes payroll buy and paid ads
was sixty thousand dollars
and so basically this guy and and then
he launched this new company called
school which is basically like a
facebook groups alternative because when
he was launching courses he was like you
stink so that is a different story
that's actually cool but this course
business this guy has now
basically let's just times it by 10 so 8
million in revenue with 600 000 in
expenses is that nutty or what is that
crazy yeah but it depends is that
sustainable and also is that going to
grow so for example
i know i don't think it's going to grow
but i think it's going to be sustainable
when i did the like all access passives
like i was making whatever 50k a month
off of the newsletter i paid newsletter
making 50k a month what were my expenses
it was like you know
300 a month for convertkit
uh you know like a va for 500 a month
whatever so it looked nutty but like
that's because i had an audience so i
could just sell into that if i wanted to
grow it i would have had to like you
know my expenses would have had to gone
way up right you know like so it depends
where
yeah maybe his ad spend is really low
now is that because his ads are ultra
efficient or is because he had a lot a
big list no they said that they don't
they don't spend ads anymore but
previously they had spent millions and
tens of millions of dollars of ads so
the website definitely already has yeah
uh traffic traffic yeah so yes it's not
like i talked to somebody who worked
there um pretty early on so they i was
like is this guy legit he's legit he's
good um they're like he he lived in new
zealand or something like that he's a
digital marketer
uh then he has consulting.com which is
basically like they had a course they
had a consulting accelerator and they're
basically teaching people how to start
their own business their own consulting
business
and uh they said they told me at the
time that there was like 10 million
dollars of free cash flow a year and
they said that um
they it was about 30 million or
something in revenue they said like half
of that so like 15 16 million was coming
from one product which was a two or
three thousand dollar course about how
to start your own consulting business
and then from there they upsell you into
the five thousand dollar course about
how to create a course
and then
uh once you get to
five hundred thousand dollars in
consulting revenue then you get to join
a mastermind that will help you get to a
million dollars plus and that'll cost
you 25 or 50 grand or something like
that and so that was their you know that
was their model but you know half of it
was coming from that kind of like entry
level
two to three thousand dollar course um
where they like kind of sell you close
you on the phone to like get you to buy
the course which is yeah i went through
the funnel to like
so i got him to sell me online
or to do the phone call and i was like i
want to figure this out
it's pretty good man and i gave the guy
a hard time because he's just kind of
weird he just comes off serial kill kind
of patrick bateman he's kind of like the
patrick bateman of our of our friend
jack smith like the american psycho
version of our friend jack smith
and
so he's like just like a little
off but that's actually really
incorrect of me to say because i don't i
think he's just an oddball which is
totally because i don't know the guy
well yeah and i don't know him and i
think that my judgment is just totally
wrong i think he's an all right guy yeah
i think it's wrong because it's all
based on his haircut
no i watched a lot of this guy's videos
and i was like something is off here and
i he was he was aggressively selling it
was the type of guy where you're selling
like a private jet uh like a video on a
private jet right so that's not wrong
but it's it's it's you know your cousins
with wrong um and so i think that that
it was just kind of odd but i thought
that was interesting i thought you get a
kick out of that all right but the
second thing so go to board google
boardroom insiders okay
so this company was just bought the
other day for 25 million dollars
and it was bought by this company called
euro money and so basically what it does
is boardroom insiders provides
executives with help on uh it helps them
with their sales marketing and
recruiting teams uh if your audience is
a c-suite executive basically it's just
a database that lists all the executives
you can think of and for a bunch of big
powerful ones it has in-depth profiles
on them and it helps you map out who
they know and um
uh you can like follow an executive and
it could like tell you like oh this
person recently changed jobs and they
claim that none of their information
comes from scraping i don't buy that but
it could be true and they also they say
that baseball
so let's just assume that's not true and
then we'll assume it is true in a second
but assuming that's not true that means
they get all of their data from
basically these editors who are just
scraping the web not scraping but like
monitoring the web and manually creating
this database of tens of thousands of
executives and then selling it for tens
of thousands of dollars
and i think that's pretty amazing and i
think that's interesting because there's
this company called pitchbook that did
something similar to this and what pitch
book did they pitch book is owned by a
publicly traded company they do like 200
million in revenue which means they're
probably worth well over a billion at
this point and what they did was they
hired these huge teams of people in the
philippines and it would basically call
vcs and ask them if they invested in
this particular company and then they
would create a list of like all right
here's we we triangulated this to
this company raised this much money at
this valuation from these five people
these five people also invested in these
things these things these things these
18 companies are growing at this rate
based off their head count growth on
linkedin
these fascinating databases is this is
this interesting yeah i always like kind
of i kind of admire a product like this
i put this into beautiful businesses
category why because
um what's the product the product is
data
uh you sell it digitally you collect it
through either automated scraping or
outsourced you know kind of phones phone
sales scripts you get every every bit of
data you add in makes your whole data
set more valuable
and and you could sell this thing for a
very high price because the people who
need it right like boardroom insiders
for example who needs it it's
who needs access to the profiles of
executives at companies it's like
you know executive recruiters
um they are willing to pay because they
make a ton of money when they place a
cmo at a company it's executive sales or
executive marketing and so it's like
people who are who have big budgets who
spend a lot of money and they don't have
the time to like go figure this out
themselves they'd rather click a button
and get the get the list
and so um
so yeah while i don't think these are
the most fun and exciting businesses to
build or like not like
that good for the world you know uh i
don't like admire them for that reasons
can be if you if you cared about it i
think if i think there's a and there's
not like i am fairly passionate about
the pitch book version crunch bass is
also a cool version that i'm like oh
that's actually pretty sick i think
there's a world where
it could be cooler
yeah
yeah maybe it doesn't look like they
have kind of like a lot of stuff on the
person so it's like
you know i'm i'm on one so this is doug
um he's the head of retail business they
have like sample profiles on their site
he's the head of retail business at
amazon okay personal interest or golf
and greek letter organizations frats i
don't know i don't know what that's
about and then it's like here's the
summary he did this before that he was
working on this before that he was
working on this it's like a resume like
golf and boofing let's go hire him
and then it was like hey he was born in
south korea grew up in kentucky it's
like yeah you want if you want to build
rapport real quick it's like here's his
wife's name
you know hey how's the wife
how's that
young
how's uh you know what here's what he's
focused on or he he's bullish on retail
business because on the q3 earnings call
they said we're bullish on retail
business it's like okay
some of this is kind of like you know
who's typing this in here uh but some of
this could be useful i i could see why
this have you seen uh on the office
michael takes notes on all of his
clients and he's trying to get trying to
teach
how to do it
yeah he goes and dwight gets to know he
goes hello mr smith how is um greg 14
year old homosexual son how was your gay
son
yeah he's like it was written in he's
like it was on green he's like and
michael he called somebody's like green
means go i said do not go there
that's what this reminds me of
oh my god that's great
um
yeah so all right so this is a cool
little website well that's it can i tell
you something uh interesting i saw so um
the one the 0.01 rule so nathan barry
came on the pod
and he was cool so he's the the founder
of convertkit he came on he was telling
us about some blog posts that either
he's written or that others have written
that he liked so i went back and i read
one of them
and i saw this thing called the 0.01
percent rule have you seen this
no okay so
it's pretty amazing i'm gonna pull up
this uh where's the blog 0.01
rule wealth let me see if i can pull it
up here um
okay i'm not gonna be able to find it
real quick here but i'll put the link in
ben if you could find it or search
nathan barry wealth ladder 0.01
so basically
the way the guys think he's like he's
like you know
um
he's like he talks about price
sensitivity he's sort of like you know
as you get more rich you um
you know the way you think about money
should change right this is like when i
came to your house and you had like cvs
receipts in the glove compartment
because you're like saving them for like
the three dollar thing you're like hell
yeah and i was like dude you just sold
your company for like many many millions
of dollars uh what are you doing with
these cvs receipts you're like ah i just
like to do it it's a habit
and so this guy talks about like
the richer you get um
you should sort of he's like he's like
this works for when you sell something
to somebody or yourself as you get to
that level basically below 0.01
of your net worth so that's
you take your net worth you multiply by
0.000 whatever you know one so it's like
uh
0.01 of your net worth so let's say
you're worth um let's do 100 million so
100 million what is it times what use 5
million right they'll use a little bit
more of a approachable number here so
um so that would be five hundred dollars
for if you have five million dollars in
net worth five hundred dollars is the
threshold
below which you don't really feel it you
don't really care or feel it you become
a little bit price insensitive below
that point so that might be like you
know opting for the night you know the
nicer hotel or like you just really
don't give a [__] you can just ball out
at a restaurant you really don't care uh
and so he draws this little curve and
he's like
at um at the first level of wealth it's
like
he calls it like level zero level one of
wealth where it's like you know your
0.01 is like
a hundred dollars or less than a hundred
dollars at that point a million dollars
yeah a million dollars would be a
hundred bucks yeah so he's like you know
at that point like you know if you're at
the grocery store and something costs an
extra dollar like you care you don't
want to buy the eggs that cost 1.99 more
you care he's like then the next level
the next jump up is you're like well i
don't care at like you know it's the way
he draws the chart it's like what are
restaurant prices then the next one's
like what are vacation prices like you
don't even really care about how much
your vacations cost the next one is like
you you know you could fly first class
and then the final one is like you know
or the next one's like you can buy a
crazy house and you know you don't
really get you're not really feeling uh
house prices as much and then the final
one is like you know what are prices
anyways like you know this is when
you're worth over 100 million dollars
like at that point most things don't
cost anything to you
and um you're pretty insensitive to the
cost of it so i'm sort of summarizing
the idea the the exact you know you can
quibble about
what you should or shouldn't care about
but i thought it was kind of an
interesting number and the reason i
bring it up is
very few people that i know
are like properly price sensitive
so there's a lot of people i know like
my dad who no matter how wealthy they've
got like the sort of like the trauma of
not having money is so deeply ingrained
in his body
that like
you know
starbucks he's just like he's like
pissed off when they charge even if he
buys the coffee it like he's angry at
the price and he's like oh my god 4.99
like i could make this for so much less
and they're like sir you're welcome to
do that and he's like oh like what's
going on and you know he's anchored to
prices from like the 80s when like you
know that's where like he thought movie
tickets should cost x and also you know
it just like hurts him to spend more
than some amount regardless of what's in
his bank account and so he's kind of on
one side of the spectrum too cheap and
then there's another side spectrum which
is where more where i am where it's like
dude you should really kind of like pay
attention to this you're kind of
spending like pretty crazy
and uh you know completely price
insensitive is on the other side and
then there's like whatever the sweet
spot is and then school they don't
really teach you how to
how to like gauge that or what what
those kind of like
what even should be a good number for
this what should i spend on things so
you you don't get nervous like i i freak
out a little because as an entrepreneur
like some years i just like knock out
the park and make so much money other
years i make nothing
i mean
hopefully i don't think nothing will
ever happen again but like there's times
you don't get nervous about running out
no actually like two months ago i was
like oh my god i have like no cash left
no cash on hand left i was i was
investing in everything i saw i was
putting money into startups and to
crypto into stuff i was then i was
spending a bunch like my payroll
expanded
and i was like oh my god i have like so
little cash in my cap
i felt
i had 60 grand in cash and i was like i
feel low yeah i think it was like 38 000
was in my like whatever wells fargo
checking account i was like where'd all
the money go this was like
and i was like oh yeah i guess and i
looked at the like out outgoing thing
and it was like it's not that my
spending had gone up i was really just
investing a lot of money but i was like
wow i should uh i need to manage cash
for most the time for me it's like i
need to send my invoices for like things
you know like i was like all right i'm
gonna teach a course and i'm going to
invoice you know for the podcast and i'm
going to like do the things that bring
in like cash today versus most of the
things i invest my money into are like
long-term illiquid things or my own
businesses right like uh maybe i should
take a withdrawal out of my business and
like put money in my bank account and so
so you know it was just like a reminder
of that but no i don't really get too
worried about that um
and maybe you know again i think i'm too
far on the dial of like willing to spend
on whatever
ramit sethi this is pretty much what his
entire
uh not course but his entire image and
content is about which is like
he's got this podcast where two people
couples argue like we have we're worth
three million dollars and he got into a
fight with me because i spent 80
on this silly thing
and
ramit's all about that it's i have i'm
more like your father than i am like you
like
and i think it's just rooted it's it's
rooted in like trauma like just fear uh
i've got the same thing we're just like
it's like it bothers me so much like for
example um commenteer coffee um i they
sent me some for free it's so good but
it's a dollar fifty per cup
and compare that to like you being
coffee i'm like a dollar fifty sometimes
i don't even drink the whole thing
and so like i've been really struggling
with like
is that worth it is this worth it or
the backsplash on my sink in my kitchen
we need to replace it and it's 800 and
i've been fretting over it for over a
year now i'm like ugh 800 to replace
that i can't so even though it will add
value to the home and also make me
happier i understand why your dad thinks
that way it's really it's real i think
it's challenging when you're it's like
it's like
you know it's proper trauma i think of
like
you felt one way for years and now you
suddenly like things are different yeah
maybe we actually need money therapy uh
money therapy specifically i think
that's actually a good idea here so
therapy is this broad thing that has
like a bunch of associations with it and
mostly it's like stigmas and blah blah i
think somebody needs to spin off and
remember sounds like he's kind of doing
this which is
therapy's a great idea financial therapy
um and it's like yeah have a money coach
er you know you probably need a
switching therapy to coach is the hack
to like
oh i'm i'm focusing on performance and
not like uh you know
fixing a pr broken part of me
but
in reality it's that i tried finding
people like this and when i met them i
was like look
we're just getting to know each other
i'm not a financial advisor different
thing no i know
when i i would go to therapy for a lot
and i would and i would go when i
whenever i was trying out a new
therapist i'd be like so i'm not gonna
like i'm not trying to sound like a
douche or big headed but like
i'm a high achiever like i want to like
conquer the world and like do cool [__]
and so i don't want to talk like this is
this is the the place that i'm coming
from like i'm high octane baby can we
can we make this happen do you have the
tools necessary or no or do you like
specialized just in like
you know like traditional way what were
you really trying to tell her you were
trying to tell her that my problems are
not like i'm not broken i'm trying to
like just achieve a higher level of
success or were you trying to tell what
i'm going to do
therapist is that what you were trying
to ask her what were you trying to ask
him no the blunt way to explain it is
i've got rich i'm i'm complaining about
some rich people problems okay and like
i'm just like mostly just insecure about
certain things and i want to like use
that to like conquer the world i'm not
very good on twitter
yeah and like i'm gonna complain about
stuff that sounds super weak because
like on outside like everything's going
great but i need you to like empathize
that like i'm trying to like go places
and i don't need you to tell me that
like well you made a million dollars
that last year isn't that good enough
like no dog that's not like i need you
to understand like what like what's at
stake here you know what i mean
i said what is at stake here
that's like you're better i'm gonna be
i'm gonna be i'm gonna be your money
therapist but you know what i mean like
it's so like i would be people and i'm
like oh you've only worked with like a
certain type of person you have like i
don't think you unders i don't think
you'll be able to help me yeah yeah
exactly i know what you mean it's the
reason tony robbins gets paid a million
dollars plus per client because it's
like his clients are serena williams and
ray dalio and you know or whoever he's
crazy
yeah and he himself is successful and
his other clients are
you know
objectively very successful but
everybody
um you know can improve the you know the
little voice in their head dude while
we're on the random
random
random topics did you watch the tinder
swindler
no but i saw your picture with it so
what's the what's the like the the okay
so you guys don't okay so here's here's
what happened it's kind of an amazing
thing
um
there's a guy so the document it's a
documentary about this guy who goes on
tinder and his tinder profile looks like
uh you know he's kind of like a
normal-ish looking guy but he's like
clearly living a cool lifestyle like
lots of travel
in different climates kind of wearing
very nice clothes that's his profile all
right so girls swipe right on him and
they start chatting with him and he he
basically what he ended up doing was he
ended up conning women out of money and
it was like a ponzi scheme so what he
would do is he would meet a woman on
tinder take her out on a date kind of
wine in diner make it look like he's
this baller of a guy
and he you know was just like
like a prince out of a fairy tale he
just loves her the average looking girl
who's average job just for my average
city and then all of a sudden i come on
my private jet and come do this with me
and they go together and there she's
like oh my god it's all happening i am
that princess that he picked and he
cares for and so he he starts talking to
him and
his back story is that he um
his dad owns a diamond company and he's
the son of a billionaire and if you
google you see that this guy's a son of
a billionaire so he kind of like had
created this profile around that
and um
and then you know sure enough a month in
he's like um
hey you know like he's he's like oh you
know he sends a picture of his body he's
always with the bodyguard he's like my
bodyguard got attacked oh my god she's
like oh my god is he okay he's like yeah
but you know they're telling me i can't
use my credit cards anymore because
they're tracking my location you know
like these are our enemies for our
company the diamond business is a
ruthless business
and he's like uh can i borrow your
credit card for the time being while i
uh
you know because i can't use mine yet
and she's like uh okay and he's like
cool just make sure you get your limits
raised because like i have business
meetings and all this stuff
so these women end up going like 150 200
000 in debt as he racks up credit card
debt then he's like hey go get a quick
loan and send me the money i need it
because you know my enemies are after me
and he's like my enemies are after me
and so you the documentaries the first
half of the documentaries women talk
about how they fell in love and the
second half is like
how they got conned basically and he's
like a ponzi scheme so he's well he'd
fall in love with one woman or he'd get
them to fall in love with him
get them to start giving him money and
credit cards he'd be using that to wine
and dine the next woman and then he
would be doing this with multiple women
at once telling them all the same things
and then
he was living this like extravagant
lifestyle on all these women's dime
and uh
and then you know so that's that okay
that's the score of the movie quick
reaction to that and i'm gonna tell you
some other stuff well what happened to
him so how does this end it ends with he
gets exposed so the women are like oh my
god you know they they go to the credit
card company they're like look i have to
be honest like
my kind of boyfriend you know or i don't
know what's going on this is the guy
he's tricking me and like he's there can
we see a picture of the guy and he she
shows a picture on her phone and then
the two like agents from like amex or
whatever just look at each other like
it's him and then she's like what it's
like we've been after this guy for years
uh he does this with tons of women
they're like there's other women he's
doing this too and so it's like they
feel cheated on plus conned and um and
so he
but technically what happens is is he
breaking the law he's not breaking the
law they are giving him money they're
sending him money willingly and they are
um
you know they're giving him their credit
card and they're calling the credit card
company and saying no no it's me can you
please raise my limits yes i'm traveling
i'm in i'm i'm in ibiza right now and so
they're like uh you know you're in a
kind of a sticky spot you can't really
say he stole it you clearly gave it to
him uh in fact you kind of committed
fraud but like well whatever we'll leave
that aside but like yeah you do owe this
money like this is not
um this is not you know a stolen credit
card and so
anyways how much do you get he ends up
getting a 15-month sentence for not even
for this it's for like something else
that he did like associated with this um
he serves five months he gets off free
he's out there living he's got a new
model girlfriend he lives somewhere else
um
the girls kind of like exposed him in
the press because they were like okay
look law enforcement's not doing
anything or it's going to take too long
he's going to keep doing this in the
meantime
they go to the norwegian press where
they're from and they they they kind of
like expose it the netflix turns it into
a documentary
and uh and so the guy's still out there
and one of the things in the movie is he
goes to a plastic surgeon and he's like
i want my eyes cheekbones chin mouth all
restructured and this guy's like i'm not
gonna do this only a criminal would want
this surgery and
so he's like trying to change his face
so he could keep it going but he can't
change his face and now he's like you
know kind of like public enemy number
one but a lot of people who watch this
are like dude these girls are stupid you
yeah you were just with him for the
money and then he can't do for the money
you got what you deserve so the girls
are getting a ton of flack for it which
is really crazy that's that's that's
dumb
but i was just thinking what a waste of
talent by this guy
yeah like that's pretty amazing
it's like a you know what's funny is
like leonardo dicaprio played the same
character and catch me if you can and it
was awesome yeah he became like when i
see this guy i want to punch him in the
face yeah exactly
that was the problem it was a
documentary instead of
a movie about the con man itself where
you sort of fall in love with this
smooth guy uh yeah if a different if if
like a lovable if like if like matt
damon played him i would be all about it
but
you got to watch the thing super
punchable face this guy
yeah um and the memes are just amazing
uh around well i saw the meme with you
with your face on it yeah yeah yes i had
somebody i was like hey photoshop my
head onto
onto this photo where it looks like i'm
with the guy and i just tweeted out like
i'm with my sister's new boyfriend like
is he american
no this guy's there's israeli
um dude screw this guy man i i i'm happy
they made a documentary about him how
did he get all the uh so he's in a
private jet a bunch of these pictures
how did he get that
because he's using the previous woman's
money to fund his his lifestyle so he
would fly private yeah yeah so he's
actually flying private i don't know if
all the time but at least some of the
time
and uh it was just really wild in fact a
lot of the numbers don't make sense like
he must have been running this on like
tons of women at once to fund this
lifestyle because he's like the jets and
the stuff that he's doing like okay he
called this woman out of 80 grand but 80
grand funds like one month of this
lifestyle you know like that's not very
long so he must have had a lot of people
at the same time or the documentary is a
little inaccurate i don't know but how
much money did he get
they said that he had conned women out
of millions of dollars over over time
um they didn't say exactly how much they
don't know you know how much of it what
was there but but i i just feel like he
did this all wrong like if you're gonna
do all this effort
you gotta be more intelligent right like
okay what could he have done um
could have just married rich could have
just seemed rich married rich divorced
took half right like that that would
have worked uh wait wait you know put
more wood behind fewer arrows here and
he could have just caught one very
wealthy person if he really wanted to do
this that's my first critique of him uh
my second critique of him is
bro all this money to just party
partying's exhausting like why he just
wanted to fly private and go to these
clubs and do table service like
you know
you couldn't pay me to do that i don't
know
you gotta diversify your assets dog yeah
you should uh you should own some crypto
like buy something buy buy a home do do
something with this money you just blew
all the money on overpriced you know
like bottle service at the club like wow
all right that's critique number two
um
number three
go b to b bro corporate swindling would
have worked way better so you know he
could have been like you heard about the
guy who just started sending invoices to
microsoft and apple and stuff just got
paid like millions of dollars just
he was just sending an invoice to
accounts payable or whatever and uh and
then they would just pay some of the
invoices
like like ap at microsoft.com yeah he
was like he's like hey you know this is
for the blah blah blah and like
and then they went back and they were
like what the hell is this who is this
vendor that we paid 1.1 million dollars
to this year like nobody knows who this
is i don't think that's illegal either
uh i think it is because he was like you
know uh well whatever they were going
back after them you know these companies
a lot of money so that's the downside of
going b2b i feel like there could have
been a b2b way of doing this
should have actually just started a
diamond company could have made a lot
more money if you're this good at
getting women's emotions tied up in your
your lifestyle just actually sell the
diamonds it would have worked
use their money to fund a diamond
company that actually could have worked
this guy needs to be needs to be on the
facebook ad manager instead of tinder
that's my best maker
i'm looking at him now the all those
these women who he's scammed like a lot
of them look like models like he was
killing it also like you forgot the
other option which is like just marry
one of these ladies if they're rich
enough to like if they're these
beautiful women who could wire them 200k
like
i don't know man bro maybe you got to
keep her well in this case he's like he
was telling him like go take like a kind
of like a
collateralized loan or a payday loan and
like super high just don't worry he's
like i'm going to wire your money back
in four days
and then he would like not wire them
back and then they'd be like hey did you
wear the money he's like oh sorry they
are like the bank was closed okay then
he would like show them a statement he'd
be like i sent it should arrive in a
couple days
she's like hey it hasn't arrived yet
what's going on like the interest is
building up on this like flash loan you
had me take he's like oh my god let me
call the bank another two days go by
he's like called the bank they said this
thing got frozen i gotta i gotta deal
with this i'm so sorry here uh you know
i'm gonna send you one of my watches in
the meantime you could just sell it this
watch is worth a hundred thousand
dollars sends them a fake watch and you
just buy time doing that it's like these
women didn't have the money but like i
think he could he could have totally
gone for a richer woman
and then been like you know what baby
like
i love you i'm not gonna make you sign a
prenup you know me i'm a billionaire uh
i come from this lineage but i'm not my
dad says sign up prenup i'm not gonna do
it and then she would feel a little bit
of pressure and be like okay i guess i
can't really ask him for a penalty
anyways this guy's richer than me all
right i guess i also won't that would
have been a more effective con if this
guy were in jail do you think he'd be
popular or hated
i think popular sadly you think popular
i think i think popular i could see this
going either way man i could see this
i could see this going either way i
think like dude
in prison would he like all right so
bernie madoff i heard in prison was like
a god which i get i get that you know
like he could teach people how to like
corner like the chocolate chip or the
chocolate hot chocolate market like in
prison like he could like you know or he
could like you know dominate the
commissary and like teach you about
markets i get that and also there it
wasn't a violent crime so no
children or women would hurt like this
guy is he i would see this guy being
unpopular uh
i don't know that's a good question he's
got kind of like a douchebag aura to him
so that's the problem that's that's
where he's going to get in trouble but
uh
bro the swindler this window would do
well in prison
i guess i'll watch it how many episodes
he's not in prison he's out and about
he's he's living a nice life right now
i'll screw this guy man and he sold a
couple million dollars yeah i think i
think about i think this documentary is
good punishment though that's fair i'm
okay with you not serving time and you
have this documentary our buddy jack
butcher pointed something out that i was
like oh wait a minute that's true he's
like yo netflix is gonna make a lot of
money off this documentary pay off these
women's debts they have like a gofundme
going it's like yo netflix you need to
pay off this woman's 200 000 debt that's
true you did well on this documentary so
that's the uh that's the real call out
here netflix
cancel netflix if they don't pay off
these women's debts that's a no-brainer
you don't think they're going to
well nobody said anything these women
are doing interviews everywhere there's
a gofundme out there i feel like i feel
like they could have said or they're
just you know swindling people one good
thing you know we didn't make a lot of
money off this but netflix actually
generously did agree to pay off the debt
you know uh blah blah blah that i feel
like that story should have come out if
they did it if they didn't then fire
your either fire your pr person netflix
or
pay off this pay these debts you have
two choices that's actually a great
point how many likes did that tweet get
that jax had
probably not that many because now
everyone's just looking at jack for like
nft oh my god
all right that's a good episode
[Music]
you